how's it gonna read my name back welcome
back to some television watching I'm
just I'm not gonna miss all right miss
plant I need a status report okay
there's I don't I'm sorry I don't know I
get debit I love the wallpaper love it
I'm not sure where we have to make bound
no maybe upstairs perhaps it could be I
don't know
oh yeah oh no it's not there Oh nope
nope nope no oh no what the hell is that
seriously what are you talk to me know
what smash me oh god damage you're
saying ah oh no you spit in my face
alright kill it with fire okay boy but
whatever it's sort of anything
will you please kinda guy thank you
Jesus Christ gotta do everything what a
a gesture by trick that I clicks off
it's the door downstairs all right I'm
not afraid
I will lit TC 30 pesos the old rent nice
oh oh nevermind okay I get it
you want to smell good but the hairs ah
[ __ ] ah all right one mess hi double
head that's what I'm talking about
can open these No alright let's venture
downwards downward is never good in
horror games operas never good either
now I think about it right bring it brat
no all right hi
what the hell no rumors mom oh no she
makes a comeback
that sneaky Lilla she's so did I eight
health killed Reubens mom it's
impossible
it seemed pretty approachable eight
health I love it mom ah Oh tasted
Reubens mom hey dad why don't you die
I killed rumors mom like a boss
all right anyone else perhaps Reuben
himself when I man up
what the hell this is it always a party
room yeah
this okay it's not hard Oh
oh that's where the sperm shooter is I
couldn't figure out all shab nappies you
know bring it hey all of you a Leticia
my deodorant language no oh no all right
we got to take the boat again and row
ourself back I'm sailing away
yeah straight open car to virgin see ah
oh no the sperm shooter back acts nice
are you kidding him ha ha nipple guys
holy [ __ ] that a nice batter everyone I
am am down I have a trousers no what am
i doing whatever they are do alright
alright I got this like a boss
not us no señor it doesn't any on us ah
ah nipple guys everywhere I do not
expect them to respawn I have eight
health and zero town says eight health
how much ammo let me check thirteen all
right [ __ ] [ __ ] with snitchin like
snitches whatever I can try but that
does not mean I can be a rapper
alright probably not probablemente no
senior alright I got to be free free to
face a life that's a it me a mode I'm
captured because I know well Dan you
spawn kill me you [ __ ] sperm shootout
well you know what I got some moves
myself I will show them to you box from
John no well done sperm shooter all
right that didn't exactly go as plain
but move try it out again but I just try
my super sneaky moment die die die die
balk what alright you died alright I'm
actually I'm say though because dad I'll
make it hey gonna make it look he
doesn't see me oh snap he sees me axe
nice
diandra Nate um no well done sir well
done that I sneak up on this [ __ ]
smacking oh no don't smack me back it
hurts
ah what should I do lick the nipple guys
approaching to
that good all right let him I'm swingin
subpoenas day that I'm swinging spinners
day that oh no nipple guy what the hell
is still alive
oh no nipple guy oh no don't you're not
a dog holy [ __ ]
when will they learn eh my nipples Hey
oh yeah yeah alright quick same there
push it somewhat hello
alright eight health two batteries and
one do just bring it bring it bring it
all up yes eight my language ah okay I
don't think your technique you can't eat
the language but it would be pretty
hardcore oh yeah I'm hardcore enough
okay ate it and I don't eat it fine it's
probably doesn't taste that good it's
not supposed to taste good either
that's the point it it it it it did
alright see what you got
yes that's what I'm talking about
alright anyone else anyone else want a
tango I don't know it's a fangirl
alright let's just avoid eye contact boy
oh no nipple game it hate it hate it
yes sweet baby Jesus everywhere all
right let's same here see Rosie there's
nothing I can do for you I'm sorry just
let me alone all right we have three on
the left three park your stop how do i
oh it's here no oh yes
I tree hi I missed you looking good
there buddy
okay let's save here again don't [ __ ] up
pop I mean what have we got it's just
getting me okay there we go
haunted house of hell love really can't
wait to go there it looks good all right
we have a sperm shooter here [ __ ] how am
I gonna do this
this is mission impossible bring it
bring it bring it bring it
seriously how much [ __ ] can I write I
don't know I don't think you're human
but goddamn you have a lot of [ __ ] go
that did not go it's plain but there are
other planks Oh snappish know what ha oh
snap it's new double triple okay I did
it
whatever lovely bookshelf I don't like
oh stop oh come on I'm just okay I'll go
upstairs fine no Charlie stop having
your period in front of me it is
disgusting why can't we just be friends
why can't we be friends why can't we be
friends I don't know other words of that
shock Charlie Charlie this is not the
game where you chase people I know
you're upset but we're not playing right
now oh you're not supposed to have your
period just randomly I'll give you the
period oh no don't give me period I was
kidding
I'm sorry Charlie we can be friends if
you can't just shoot period in people's
faces what is this that's a long [ __ ]
ammo where does it go not my butt that's
for sure ah pockets the
see SMG gun and I don't have it
look zero zero zero everything is at
zero except yeah even the battery no not
the battery well it says on sir but it
still has all right fine
whoever saying hey let me just grab the
owner let me just grab that how you
doing all right stupid oh no I'm not a
flashlight
I should probably stab em deodorant
deodorant oh no I don't see anything oh
no he got me well done sir
good all right let's try this again
I like us sir okay eat it I know you
like deodorant which fragrance is your
favorite just one what three hits
usually counselor I don't get it
Yo no comprendo all right tres uno
cuatro okay that was not a quieter but
whatever stress yes yes you now smell
good for the rest of your life because
you're dead and you never smell good
anyway now let's cook some bacon shall
we I only have guns I don't know how to
cook bacon with guns oh god damn it what
is the point of this room anyway really
there's something here oh wait I got the
shotgun and although I did get the
shotgun and I'm very thankful really
thankful I think maybe we have to jump
up here feels good to be a genius
sometimes you know some guys why just
going on here
Alistair I'm making anyone have a
problem with me going on The Blair Witch
Project house with an evil witch a
disrepair what back to the church no
snow
oh snap it's two snaps everywhere ah
come on lazy huh come on Toby far limber
that I don't like - no I don't know I
don't I don't want to anymore and I'd
like a favor she enjoys this guy to come
a roadie and I'll see you next episode
ah I want to add is that supposed to
mean Oh God
how did I - is the first time home yes
all right
god dammit it's all your fault I'm sorry
day
Oh No